hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode is brought to you by the great
todd's racing who is one of the greatest
harness trainers in new zealand
so go give todd's racing a follow on
facebook and twitter
it would be much appreciated also the
woodland coffee bean
now i'm getting great feedback from
anyone who's given this coffee bean a go
it is freshly roasted so go get yourself
some water lead coffee bean by heading
to waterlab.com
clicking the pomeroys logo or head into
pomeroy's cafe if you live in nelson
and ask for the water bean you will not
regret it anyway i got a good one for
you today so let's roll the intro
[Music]
guys today i have an absolute treat for
you all in the form of one of new
zealand's great lads
and a new zealand rugby legend he's
played for the new zealand
age grade reps more times than anyone
else on this planet he was also the face
of the southland stags
he was the ultimate highlander and he
was also a chiefs legend
and as well as all that he'd achieved
his ultimate goal of becoming an all
black
and since then he's played for teams
including ohio montpellier poe
and austin but what he's probably most
well known for
is being an absolute lad he's one of the
greats
it is of course jamie whopper mcintosh
welcome whoops
welcome diddy great to have you on mate
mate
so many teams you've seen it all you've
been everywhere
what a career yeah it's been a hell of a
ride the last seven years as we'll
probably
catch up on but um not pumped to be on
here but i've been doing plenty of
travel and listen to plenty of the
podcast and um
particularly enjoyed the one with you
and tojo um so i was always looking
forward to getting on here and
chewing the fat with you oh mate it's an
absolute pleasure so where are you at
the moment you're in isolation
yeah um i'm in road aurorable places
yeah
day six into isolation
yeah look it's a bit of a bizarre
feeling really like had six months just
um i left new zealand to go to austin
and we arrived there and
covered was a pretty big part of our
team we're living in bubbles and
training in bubbles and masks and
it was a pretty tough time and then we
were all vaccinated and double
vaccinated and
um after that the last three months
we've been living life normally over
there and founded a bit of a shock to
the system coming back to new zealand
and
you know i guess the stigma around
covert and just the way the country's
gone
differently about it compared to you
know say america where they've learned
to live with it and
yeah sitting in iq is a little bit of a
strange feeling to be fair
how have you been keeping busy i've been
really lucky um
had lots of work on with the otago team
yeah i'm
reviewing and previewing from the laffy
here um got a what bike on dick
and i'm really lucky in the same hotel
we've got um
pili kelly who played with me uh jason
robinson from counties last year
in uh dan hornstein who's playing for
auckland season so we go for walks in
the yard
catch up and chew the fat so you're back
with otago coaching them this season is
that right
yeah um yeah i was really lucky last
year i'd come back to new zealand just
before the country shut down
um was really still playing rugby and um
was offered a bit of a lifeline
to go down to southwind or otago and one
of my good friends well
best friend tom dorney kid coaching
otago and i ended up lining up here and
um being the scrum coach and i think i
ended up playing nine or ten games and
absolutely loved it and yeah managed to
wear my way back into a full-time
coaching gig there with the fords this
year which i'm
super pumped about mate and you've got a
pretty impressive squad on paper you'll
be
looking forward to getting your hands on
these boys yeah i can't wait
um particularly our back line is pretty
exciting but
you're not doing the backs are you i
should be
i always told daniel i was the first one
stuck in a props body um nah ricky
flutie is a really talented coach
he's got the attacks and attack and yeah
look we're really disappointed last year
we blew out in the semi-finals and we
had the squad to go through and
you know probably take cook spay down in
that final but um hopefully we'll learn
to listen to
would you chuck the boots on this year
look i just come off 15 games over in
america and
the rugby over there was really tough
this year and still really enjoying my
footy and
i think playing some of my best footy
actually into my 30s so
uh i really want to develop the boys
down there but if there was an
opportunity to play i'd love to
but um i think my first focus is you
know we've got to
got to get the sport pack going so we
can get those back some good ball and
um so i'll probably get down there and
knuckle into it but i would love to
think that i'll play one or two games
but that's good stuff
and are you back to austin next year or
is was that your time done over there
now look at really really exciting time
for our team personally
austin where we've got joint ownership
with um
la and the guy who owns our team guy
called adam gilchrist
not the cricketer uh a really successful
businessman in australia he's
only 42 he played australian school boys
rugby and knows a lot of the rugby men
and
he actually founded 45 and moved went to
america and
saddled up with uh mark wahlberg and and
it made an absolute fortune now to be 45
over there and we're lucky that he owns
both our teams and
yeah look it's it's really optional like
my team wants me back
next year to coach the forwards and
maybe play one season it's just been
such a
you know such a hectic last couple of
months i just need to uh
get back take a breath and do a good job
for otago and make a good decision
around that
but he actually adam just floated at 45
last week and
he what did he make i think he cleared
370 million
on the opening day that the uh
so his net worth or the company was
worth uh
1.5 billion wow it went up six percent
so he had a good day
paid for our tyre float which was a good
start true talk me through that tyre
float i saw
some uh footage on your instagram and it
might have been uh big seb de chavez as
well
you guys look like you're having a hell
of a time yeah mad monday we um
took a bus out to the river and they
drop you off with a whole lot of floats
and chili bins that float and speakers
that float and
we spent five hours floating down the
river drinking beers and
um yeah we ended up trying to have a
cordy after that which wasn't that
successful so
uh yeah real real good mad monday
who was running the quarter yeah no they
wanted me to i sat in the back i
i i um i prefer to watch these days and
uh yeah they run it very poorly to be
fit that they are
you would have been itching to take over
no doubt
i wasn't on them in such a who um but
yeah
typical stuff broken tv two chairs and
an extra 600 on the
airbnb bill so the boys are sort of
fighting their way through that at the
moment who's airbnb was it
like last time you stuffed up my airbnb
i had to delete my account
[Laughter]
i left my car there for six weeks i went
on holiday when i went to pick up my car
i was so scared about seeing that chat
and i could see her in the kitchen and i
crawled i crawled
underneath the fence and got in my car
and just blatted it
she wanted me off this earth because you
pissed her beard i'm
still filthy at that i did not persevere
who's tojo's mate monkey
oh yeah my suspicion was monkey actually
that was probably the worst egg that
i've ever been a part of
what about our beer table trip he just
took us out to a road in the middle of
nowhere and we peddled like
60 meters yeah well tojo's put me in the
most random
spot in a new country i've all tried to
organize through these tours
and they've absolutely let me down big
time it was a blowout that was a good
time
we ended up not even drunk not even
drunk jumped down
barcelona and speedos and yeah it was
pretty [ __ ] awkward
you must have been drunk you were
wrestling fonetiere on the beach
everywhere
mate that is one man that i'm scared of
drinking he
he attacked me the night before and i
had to succumb i i'd had enough
and uh i had a purple patch on the beach
and i wanted to take him down but it
wasn't a great idea
oh good times oh how was big isaac ross
in the interview
he is a good man yeah he's good the boys
called him the mounted candle over there
he's got a body like a mounted candle so
if i enjoyed it
oh you know what zack he's like he's a
he's a great fella
yeah really enjoyed it
took his four kids and his wife over
there and you know i hope they settled
in for next season and
me and him are co-coaching the forwards
and i enjoyed working with him it was a
good time
oh nice is he coaching them next year
with you potentially or
still going to play i think the both of
us are still going to play and coach
so nice look it's a hard balance to get
right to be fair yeah
it's a lot of work so you've got to wrap
your head around and go in there fresh
because
six months of like properly prepping a
food pack week to week can be
and playing is not much time off but
it's a lot of fun
so yeah if we go back i look forward to
getting into it again definitely
all right how good is that anyway we've
got so much to get through on this
on this run sheet here what so much so
much has happened in your career but we
need to start at the start
i mean i'm not sure if you're ever
little but um as little as you were
talk me through your times growing up
yeah um
from the farm was really lucky had a
great i've still got a great family
mum there two older sisters and the
younger brother and um
yeah just a magic upbringing on the farm
taught us a lot of our work ethic and
and i guess a little bit about toughness
into like sticking at things and
um yeah unfortunately i was big when i
was young and
i never made an age group well you used
to have under 58
under 65 and i'd cry myself to sleep
right until i was 13 because i never
made any of these teams
how big were you first thing i remember
my first year in high school
i was uh third form was 87 kilo
oh yeah and then i put on 10 kilos a
year right through to 16 so
i went 97 for form 108 perform
and then 116 6 form i think seven four
miles one twenty two
holy heck boys it's ridiculous i don't
know
what i think i used to drink a lot of
milk that's a lot of milk you're
drinking
i drank a lot of milk but i was never
130 clicks
but we always were you always good at
rugby like through your age groups even
though you
you're big you obviously dominated them
in terms of size but
did you know you were going to be quite
a good rugby player oh
i i think around 10 11 12 i was
i was playing number eight i was i
wasn't that big or fat but i sort of
chucked on that weight over high school
but i did
start to get really super competitive
and you know you start realizing guys
that you're playing against and start
wanting to beat them and
yeah it was probably then when i sort of
really realized i was competitive and
then
yeah when i hit high school was when my
rugby all took off really like i
went into the under 15 tournament team
when i was 12 i had three years of net
in the first 15 and yeah look i i
always loved rugby from when i was young
um
from all of my dad's mates they still do
it now five of them meet up and watch
every all black tears every world cup
game and
i usually still love going around to the
houses and playing footy against the
other kids and
watching the old blacks play you know it
was just how we grew up and it was
always what i wanted to do and always
what i told my parents what i wanted to
do was play professional rugby so
that was from when i was about 13 so
that was pretty cool to actually
to do that so when did you move from
eight into the front row
uh when i was 12 that first year of high
school so i went 12 13 i was a young guy
so i went into hooker and um
yeah like for the next few years i was
always playing guys a lot older than me
and i was [ __ ] myself so
i think that's where i learned a little
bit about myself um
went from hooker then to prop and four
form and then
was basically propped for the whole way
through and to um verse 15 where
we had a really successful first set
there we made the top four twice
into three years got knocked out to the
sydney final against napier and i think
one to rotorua so
yeah we had a class team and a lot of
guys went on to play itm cup and quite a
lot of super players actually
right and you're obviously a big part of
that success because
yeah like i said in the intro you played
so many games like what was it i think
32 games for new zealand age grade
that's
unbelievable stuff so what year did you
first make new zealand schools
yeah it was crazy um jimmy to be fair
like
so the first year 2001 i was only 16 and
our team made the top four we played
rotorua in the semi-final
and after they named the squad for the
new zealand schools and i'd made it
in fact we toured the uk um so as a 16
year old i was picked
in that time in say september and then
after
christmas day we all met up in auckland
we had like a
crazy squad you couldn't be in a thing
joe roca coco
um john afowa oh you couldn't it was
crazy
i think there was 18 all blacks in it
and we taught the uk as our new zealand
schools team for
six weeks and i played um eight tests
um and then come back for a week went to
school and then flew back up to
palmerston north and made the new
zealand number 19 world cup squad
that went to italy and then actually the
day that they were flying to italy
there's a little story um
cause i was only 16 they deemed me too
young for the tournament
so i got called into the coaches room
with all the management i was like [ __ ]
i thought i'd done something wrong
because
um i was remembered with thomas waldron
like i hadn't even seen a naked girl
before and thomas he loves the story he
took me to the strippers like
two nights before and uh
i i thought that they knew that i'd gone
to the strippers and they were gonna
drop me
so i walked into this room and i was so
nervous
and um and then they ended up saying hey
look bad we're real sorry we couldn't
get a dispensation so
the team flew to italy and i flew back
to beautiful invercargill but
at that stage i've got to keep my gear
and that was the main thing
how did you get into the strippers did
you look really old as well even though
you were 16.
and i looked like this when i was about
15.
you must have been pretty good though
like that's no mean feet hey like to
be in there at that age so you obviously
physically develop pretty early
but you obviously had the talent to back
that up as well
yeah i i mean things were happening so
fast that
i was just doing things instinctively
and i would do things i think that would
like make the eyeball carry or i
remember my first test running on that's
like we were going to play the english
under 19s and
it was the first test of that tour and i
was in the stadium in
my number ones and jerry davison the
coach come up to me is like
about 10 minutes into the game saying um
hey go down and tell the reserve prop
that you're going to swap stuff with him
i want you to play in the second half
i went down and tapped this guy jackson
bowed up on the shoulder and almost 16
i'm like hey uh i think i've got to grab
your shorts and socks and
he's like [ __ ] off honestly i didn't
have boots mouth guard
so it was really bizarre like i didn't
even do the national anthem or the
hacker and
i went into the changing room got into
these blokes boots that were too small
and walked out and and when i run onto
the field like
the first thing i did was the english
guy ran at me and i tackled him and
ripped the ball and ran the other way so
it was like a real big thing like yeah
and then just something i always sort of
was a bit tinny and did stuff like that
um yeah i don't know i just ended up in
a pretty fortunate position where i
played um
a lot of a lot of age group rugby he had
a lot of adidas here at home
yeah as a 16 year old kid living the
absolute
dream so did this mate did this give you
the confidence to
that you knew you were going to become a
professional rugby player from here and
potentially go on to be an all black did
you feel pressure after
being such a success at a young age yeah
i did feel pressure about only
i felt pressure because people who put
them themselves in that system
normally get out of that system by these
two things like being lazy or turning up
unfit or
i just had a lot of pressure on myself
from that young age that i wanted to be
really fit and i never wanted to let
people down in that
kind of area so whatever camp was coming
up um even at a 16 year old i'd learned
how to train really hard
um and that sort of i think that sort of
kept me in that program
for a for a long time because i was
elusive prop who was you know
125 kilos who could you know
play 80 minutes and and i think more so
after the age group stuff when i started
playing it
couple i felt the pressure of what i'd
done before that you know
coming into itm cup as a 19 year old
with a big reputation and
coming into super squads at a young age
i was like [ __ ] myself and
i knew that i wasn't like probably at
that level yet but
i did play item cut really young against
a lot of good people
like scrumming it's carl hayden k
schmooze greek southern mall
um learned a lot of lessons the hard way
yeah unfortunately
and it's so tough for a prop a like you
don't see many props playing
item cup at 19. well there's one story
about i come
straight out of school and was playing
for the honda's development team which
was a first-class team back then and we
used to get
two and a half grand a week or something
because it was christmas
so we were up training with the horners
and we had a game against them and
i don't know why they played me a tight
head against the proper hondas but we
didn't really push them scrums
then later on in that year southland
played otago on carrisborough and
um i remember running off the running on
the field
and i could hear carl heyman anton
oliver there was um calvin middleton few
real gozo like
we gave this little puppers [ __ ]
chance let's let's [ __ ] murder him
today
like they reminded me the whole game
that i was just like
sitting there sucking on my thumb being
like when is this going to be over
um yeah you can
certainly was intimidating at times but
i guess i hung in there and learned a
lot
were you confident in your ability
coming up against these guys or
[ __ ] no nah
i was to be fair i was confident in my
ability around the field
yeah at all times to keep up with
whatever team i was in
um just scrummaging is so hard for a
young prop and particularly
a prop my size being tall and i never
found the right recipe for my
scrummaging my whole career there was
lots of different reasons but there was
one thing that i did was work really
really hard at it
for example you know we didn't have a
lot of um
class tight heads at the hondas through
my time there we always had a scrum that
was under pressure
but at the same time i could have been
better and then i think i
really only started to scrum well in new
zealand
my my last year up at the chiefs when i
was about 30.
um and interestingly enough when i
kicked on overseas
um i went into the top 14 in france
which is probably one of the hardest
scrumming competitions in the world and
look i ended up playing 75 games over
there and
i think one season there was actually
one of them one of the biggest accolades
i got i was like one of the top lucids
in the top 14 and
for me it was just a thing sort of i
started to understand things a lot
better and
get it right and um yeah
personally it wasn't i felt really
really good about myself over there that
i could
be confident against some of the best
heads in the world and
as i said sitting in the change room
after a game having a beer knowing
that you're competent at your job and
then the guys in the room thought that
you
or you know you can feel that from the
other players when they know that you're
good at your job it was
yeah probably some of the best feelings
of my life and it was a bit of a shame
that it was overseas
in france but um still for me it was um
wicked like
i think coming back from playing for
otago last year i put a lot of pressure
on myself to transfer what i
learned in france back into otago and
look i scrubbed
um really well in the itm cup and was
was really happy to come back and
put that back on to new zealand and saw
to be fair um so what what is it about
the scrum that
takes so long for guys to sort of learn
can can you teach that
craft or is it something you just have
to go through and learn from experience
because i mean a lot you hear it a lot a
lot of props don't really feel like
they're
scrummaging at their best to win into
their 30s so
why does it take so long i think young
like some guys everybody's different
yeah um
[Music]
[ __ ] taller guys do take longer like
myself
um you know like look at the scrutiny
that white had to go through for his
career around being long
and always going on about you know the
same stuff hands on the ground and
a lot of people don't understand the ins
and outs of scrummaging which is fine
but
i hate the pressure that sometimes
people put on
younger players to come through and like
you look at the current crop of new
zealand props
um guys like angus arbor and
um like arthur moly and all the boys
like uh particularly offer like other
was a 22 year old
running around against me when i was 30
and he was exceptional
rugby player still finding his way with
the scrimmaging and now look at him he's
one of the best scrummages in the world
i don't think there's any particular
recipe i do think that
the two props in mike time who got good
really quickly were say
uh being tamiya thunder and iron franks
they were really good at 22 and
like ben was an exceptionally large
talented guy and
i've been tommy fernandez owen franks
was
an exceptionally strong dedicated guy so
those two guys had special qualities
that made them the best in the world at
a very young age i think
sure it's interesting hey it's a real
real art real craft to it
i'd love to i'd love to get in there one
day but
we normally do it on the bears jimmy
i think hojo rates himself as a
scrambler so
much i can't wait to bury him
oh i'm sure he'll scrum against you
after a couple no doubt every time i
appears with tojo after
six he just stares at me for like an
hour and he just wants to scrub me the
whole night
oh he loves it but anyway mate back to
you
we've talked about you making your
southland debut
really young but you also were called to
the highlanders really young as well so
do you want to talk about how you got
your first crack into the highlanders
because
it wasn't conventional was it no like i
was picked in the squad out of
i think in 2005 i got greek cooper rang
me up and named me in the full squad of
like so back then you had four props
um yeah but unfortunately i had a
a meeting with the all black coaches in
a hotel room and in the cargo and there
was
steve hanson graham henry and they just
said look we think you're too young you
can do with another couple years away
from this so
yeah i ended up saying no and i went
from
what a 65 000 contract to a 10 000
training contract um
which evidently might have been good i'm
not too sure but
um yeah i didn't i didn't debut for the
hondas until 2007
i think i was 21 um and
that was my first season played three or
four games but it wasn't
anything special i was just um come off
the bench and
played a handful of games my first
season in 2008 was when i
really got my opportunity started every
game that year and
um got four to the year and ended up
getting impacted the all blacks off the
back into that
yeah crazy so was it your decision to
pull out of that highlanders or
had they sort of told you or was it
their call well when
you have your black coach sittings
telling you this isn't a good idea and
your end goal is to be an all black yeah
you're not going to not listen to them
and
um no i happened again in my career
around honors captaincy actually
um so through 2008
i was really lucky i was super young
made that all blacks as a 22 or 3 year
old and
yeah i like was so like making nail
blacks is a scary experience it's an
amazing one but
there's certainly a lot of emotions that
go with it that people don't understand
and
um i remember the back end of that tour
the behind was
like i was 22 and they were hal bent on
me being the homeless captain for the
next sort of five to ten years
um they were ringing me every day and
i was in a meeting with graham henry and
steve hanson and
they basically said hey look bud we want
you to concentrate on your ugly and
we don't think that you need the extra
pressure of being home as captain so
we advise you not to do it strongly so
i turned down the honda's captaincy in
08 and 9 and then yeah evidently i never
got picked back in the all blacks
but i don't regret that decision because
i think they were looking out for what
was best for me um
but the thing is evidently in that
environment i took a massive leadership
role anyway so
i was doing what i was going to do
anyway that's crazy i've never heard of
the all black coaches having such
a big say on guys careers like that yeah
and
like they were really good about it it
just it just pissed me off because i got
stuck between
my homeless coach glenn moore who was an
absolute great guy and then
the all black coaches and them telling
me one thing and i'm like mate why don't
you guys just ring each other and
save me going between each other and
feeling like [ __ ] yeah um
because like yeah it's not fear of me
i'm only 23 and
you know [ __ ] of course i want to be the
homeless captain
but yeah like everything happens for a
reason i guess and i think jimmy cowan
took the
homeless captains here for that time and
um
i was living with him and yeah reader
where to help him out
for a couple of years to begin yeah mate
you you were captain
of southland at a young age as well so
what was it about your
game or leadership style that everyone
wanted to make you kept them
i know maybe i was big um
i didn't mind a beer in the afternoon um
nah i always had a massive um
a really good understanding of rugby
yeah um and loved it as well and
i had a good understanding when the team
didn't understand things so i quite
often
asked silly questions on behalf of the
group knowing that i knew it but other
guys
you know that was what started from a
young age and then it was funny i
i used to like speaking in front of the
team a lot the older it got particularly
the last few years i
actually get quite nervous speaking in
front of groups and teams but
when i was young they'd come really
naturally to me and
then i think you'd come back to
what i said to you before like i always
kept fit for a big guy
i always prepared really really well and
i love that saying that we always talked
about well a few people do that
there's talent and then there's things
that don't require talent which is
um there's a list of eight or nine of
them about being punctual wearing the
right stuff
being coachable having a good work ethic
and i think i was really strong in that
area
probably why i'm 36 and still playing to
be fair
mate that's powerful stuff powerful
stuff mid podcast from the big what
yeah i love that i feel like we'll peril
off that movie where i just
wake up wherever
let's go we need to get you back to that
place a little bit more throughout this
podcast that's
that's where all the gold is but you did
mention about your all blacks
um we all blacks cameos so you played
one
official test for the all blacks talk me
through that the moment you're getting
called in
how you felt about the whole experience
um well i got named on the farm and i
had all my family out on the farm
and it's about 10 30 in the morning and
they all started drinking like pretty
heavily
and uh then i needed to be at the
airport too and no one could drive so
the
local pub had to come pick us up and
drive us in which was
a pretty funny start um then
you know look it was a pretty crazy
experience um i got along really well on
that tour
with andrew tony woodcock uh jason eden
um there's a whole lot of us actually
but yeah my first test was pretty hard
like
um was scrumming against the guy you and
murray at that stage was in the lions
and one of the best props in europe and
oh at times i did really well and at
times i struggled
but the perception was that i was really
poor i haven't
to be fair i'm not lined to i've
actually never watched that game again
that's right
um and it's probably a period of my life
where i
i'm proud of what i did but i actually
look back i'm still a little bit
like yeah i haven't quite gone back and
to delve
deep into that but my second game
against monster was really really cool
um but believe it or not when you get
given your all black jersey and you go
back to the room they presented to you
my name was about wrong so it was mac
into
that's a big achievement i'm like yeah
my name's about wrong and he's like [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] like
go down and tell all the managers and
possible and i was like no i'll be right
man i'll just get through the game
um yeah so there's always a little story
that comes along with me and my
experiences that was my first saw black
one
sure um yeah and then that was it i
think
about 2010 we're playing really well for
southland and
i've got to call up possibly to go back
over to europe but they ended up taking
a tight hit
and that was probably as close as i've
been to getting back into the squad i
think
once they settle with white who's a
great player and a great bloke
um it was really me and him versus woody
really
and back then unfortunately there was
only one prop on the bench so you would
generally carry another tight hit and
that sort of limited our opportunities
for selections and what have you not
so if they had that rule do you think
you would have played a lot more games
for the all blacks
oh it's hard to say denny um but when
you put two lucids on
on the bench it's not just tony wilcock
is it so
every test match is either going to be a
me or white on the bench at that stage
and
you know they would have pulled woody of
after 60 minutes and
you know you look at how many props are
capped now because of that rule and
that's a fantastic rule um you don't
have to have a prop learning two sides
of the scrums and having a whole lot of
[ __ ] collapse crumbs in the middle of
a test match so
uh yeah to answer your question yep
i think a lot of us would have played a
lot more rugby but um
that's life really it is life so did you
feel confident as an all black in that
environment did you feel like you
belonged there or
did you feel really uncomfortable a
super uncomfortable man and even more
uncomfortable after my first test like
i doubt like everybody in the team oh
you know what i mean when things don't
go that well and
i was really hard on myself as well when
i played um
just remember sitting in the team room
just wanted to go home yeah
um but i got another crack and i
actually played
uh pretty well against munster um even
though that game was really really close
it was a super amazing experience
uh tomlin park um bono dropped the ball
off in a helicopter it was the first
time this stadium opened and
you know they nearly beat us to be fair
but in that game i scrum really well and
had a pretty good game around the park
and played 80 minutes and
yeah i was proud of that game um just
unfortunately i never
got another go back in there to like you
know give it a crack
disappointing yeah so what what would
you do differently looking back would
you
is there anything that stands out that
you do differently if you had the chance
again
that's a good question um
and the way that i turned every stone on
the well
and you know you can even ask every team
i was in i was
always trying to to find the recipe for
my scrummaging and
i would do special things i would go see
chrono for three days i would
be doing different things in the gym and
like all my focus was around how can i
become a better scrummager because i
knew if i got that right
um then that would boost me back into
the all blacks and
there was opportunities and times my
career where i thought about
there's an opportunity for me to go to
the crusaders or go to the hurricanes to
and i thought [ __ ] yeah here's another
opportunity to scrum with better players
at that stage and
to be fair did he know like i wouldn't
have done anything differently maybe i
would have acted a bit more mature
on that tour um back in 2008 because
when you weren't playing
we had a big group that weren't playing
we used to have a lot of fun like not so
much drinking but
um i sort of become a bit of the team
larkin on the bus because i had to do
the music and everybody would abuse me
and then
i ended up having to tell jokes and like
you know those kind of guys that yeah
i like naturally fell into that role and
and that was just what it was but
um i had fun doing that as well but
maybe if i'd have been a bit more
frank's like
i think i would have been in there
surely not it must mean bad jokes if
that cost you you
cost you more all black games well that
is isn't corey jane's
book the the joke i told about steve
hansen it was i'm pretty
good one what was that i'm telling you
you never really forgive me to be fair
go on what was that i haven't read it oh
i should have read it
oh it's nation it's um
basically it was after whale's test and
the music wasn't working all the boys
were throwing stuff
at me and i was like man i didn't even
have an ipad i had to cut cds back in
and this bus was like not working
and they were like you've got to tell a
joke and i told this joke about
the long story short it's about steve
hanson and allie williams and
that ali williams used to go spend
christmas holidays at steve hanson's
place
and um they both loved beating on horses
and steve went to the tab and turned
around and ali was there and
ellie's like are you going [ __ ] off home
you're too young ellie's like i'm not
and he goes
well can you dick touch your [ __ ]
now he's like no i can't he goes well
that means you're too young to go home
[Laughter]
so shag stumbles home from the tab and
he walks into ali's room and
ali had all this cash on his bed and uh
shag was sitting there being like
oh i've lost all my money and he goes oh
yeah well give me something yours and
ali said to share can you dick touch
your ass and shag said you can he goes
well you can go [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
on the bus he was standing right beside
me
and the whole bus lost it like they were
loving it because it was all like
relative to their horses in there and he
just looked at me and goes
good joke [ __ ] and i was like oh jesus
started sweating and then the worst
thing is about it he grabbed the mic and
told a joke about me and ali
and he's very sharp-witted like he's a
funny man
and this one day he got the puck he got
the punchline wrong
and then the whole bus just started
going
and i sat down in front of him and i was
so embarrassed
and then for the next two weeks on the
tour he'd just lean over and poke me in
the shoulder he goes any more
jokes geez no wonder you felt
uncomfortable in the environment
no that was later on in the tour but um
yeah look at probably looking back there
probably could have been better jokes
um it was a beauty
oh that's good
oh anyway we'll go crack on with the
career
and you're southern stags career
obviously you're
you were a hero down there with the
stags and um a lot of it revolved around
a long run of shield defenses i guess so
any good memories that stand out from
the 2009
shield defenses yeah i think winning the
shield obviously was a great thing in
2009
it was a really cool time because we
were super successful we
needed to beat canterbury in the last
game to make the major playoffs that's
out of all 14 teams which was a big deal
yeah so we ended up beating canterbury
for the shield
and then making the major semi-final
against wellington the next week
um yeah winning that shield with
guys that i like hardy scratcher jason
rutledge and
david hall
the guide james wilson robbie robson
scott cowan
that to me was a more um it was a lot
different feeling for making new blacks
it was more of a complete
utter like jubilation of doing something
extremely amazing with your best mates
and knowing that you're just going to
send it for about four days after
um like there was no holes on turn it
was just it was
it was one of the best feelings of my
life and then you know we went back and
partied at the hotel that
that friday thursday night we flew back
into
in the cargo on the friday um and
arrived at the airport there was 7 000
people at the airport we were there for
four hours
wow um people just giving us stubbies
and we're assigning stuff
and then we're at the state sale house
that's been hard
um did the yes please yes please
and then the next day that was really
funny like
jason carwell who was a vice captain
kenny lynn all great guys
the coaches texas said right you stupid
i can't well probably
shouldn't say that on the podcast but
you stupid cnts we've had a great couple
of days we've got a major semi final
against wellington next week pulley
heads and no drinking
so we got in a car and drove around
there was roger clark
david henderson simon cohen on that side
me
jason cowell kenny lynn on the other and
we just went to hammer and toms
we're like we're drinking they're like
you're not like we are like we haven't
had a beer together like we've just been
around people like
we want to sit in a room and just
celebrate winning the shield like
we actually want to take the shields on
the tour around all the country pubs
whereas boys grew up
so our coach was like after like an hour
and a half the right the only condition
is we'll drive the vans and you boys
can't drink a whole lot
so really yeah happy days um
it was the most incredible day of my
stags career where dr we arrived at the
riversdale park where jason's family's
from
there was eleven hundred people there
and then we got bagpiped in they've
never had a crowd like that in the pub
yeah we went to the gore pub we went to
the takanoi pub where i was from
it was about a six-hour bus trip and
everywhere we went was
bagpipes people crying um
and the best bit about it is we ended up
back at the northern invercargill about
eight o'clock and there was a wedding
in the reception room and the bride and
groom come through and like
they were so excited that we got invited
into their wedding and we ended up
spread out through the wedding and
board shorts and something like that
eating food
we had the shield we got pictures with
her and we listened to the speeches and
like got on the pistols wedding the
whole night it was so crazy
um yeah and then on that sunday yeah
we got put on the line we got flogged
there was um a lot of boys lost their
lunch on the sunday
um but yeah we went up and nearly won
the game against wealth and we lost in
the last play of the match
true the boys were in the sheds crying
like it was
genuinely thought we were going to win
the comp yeah um
we just had that feel about us that
swagger about us and then we lost and
all the boys were crying you could tell
how much you meant to them and then one
of the boys got up and said
hey lads we've got the ram philly share
on our way to queenstown tomorrow and we
just hope the boys started roaring and
we went on like a four-day trip around
queenstown with the shield so we had
plenty of good times mate it sounded
like you guys had an unreal culture down
there like you said it was like a group
of mates just playing for each other
you probably weren't the most talented
squad in the comp at the time but man
you guys
were playing for each other yeah and i
think the hondas were really struggling
at that time
and unfortunately we enjoyed going home
to play for south or more which is wrong
like super rugby should be the team that
you give the most to and
i felt like and i felt that in my team
that i had a far stronger culture in the
southern team
at that time through that period of
really
tough holland and stuff but um yeah look
it was a special team and
unfortunately the decline of south and
rugby has been a little bit sad and and
i was part of the first four years of it
and
um we were on the right track to be a
strong union for a long time and
a lot of political things happened and
and look where the union is now it's in
a bit of a bad way to be fair
but even in 2011 you had another good
shield cameo didn't you
yeah we were only half the team then we
we won it off canterbury we lost our
first two games we
we won it off canterbury with a drop
goal and then defended against
um poorly against counties and poorly
against north harbour
um i think taranaki i think you've
always come down
craig clark scooter jason eaton who
great
like good friends of mine who i like was
actually gutted to lose
the shield but i was like so rap that a
couple of my mates that i
respected had wanted off me and they had
a good time with it as well so that's
what it's about really
right that is what it's all about the
shield anyway we'll go to
your highlanders you were told not to be
captain
early on but then you did eventually
become captain jamie joe gave you the
captaincy of the highlanders was that an
easy decision for you at this time
yeah it was um but back then and even
now jamie's uh he's one of the best
coaches i've had or in a lot of them
um but he's a pretty intimidating guy
and he was backed in
with his wellington team as well he
trained them hard and he was a very um
a very big part of the direction of the
team
and he brought that down into homes he
was exactly what we needed at that time
and
it was a um it was an easy option it was
an easy thing but
i had lots of work to do with jamie he
put um
he put me under lots of different
pressures which i learned a lot about
myself and
yeah look we had a really good team like
both years
i was 11012 we missed out on the
playoffs by one game
i remember like we had a good squad too
with jose gear tommy allison
slady up front we had nasimanu and hards
and
josh bikus and uh like we had a really
good team and we just missed out so
we're like
we're building and building a building
and then unfortunately in 2013
it was a bit of a crazy year for the
organization and me personally they
you know corey had come down and he had
brought woody
down uh corey took over the captaincy
they bought woody they bought
nanu they bought thorne and we had this
amazing team but we
lost eight games in a row so we lost our
identity a bahamas man we had signed up
to hold up
recruits that i don't know if they
didn't perform it just didn't click um
so i remember we're in the kings and
where it was our seventh game of the
season and the kings and they were [ __ ]
um i was sitting in the stands because
obviously i wasn't playing because
i went from captain to woody coming in
jamie said it's my jersey to lose so i
turned up fit and won like a 17-6 yo-yo
at 130 kilos and
woody turned up after all that camp and
run like a 15
one and i i was playing well in the
preseason but he started woody like it
was always going to be woody that
paid a whole lot of money to get him
here and the team that run out to play
the kings was
tony wilcock andrew hall chris king brad
thorne josh because john hardy moses
thailand
aaron smith kong slade um
we had tammany allison i think
sean treby ben smith
uh kate pokey and jose gear
so like there's 14 all blacks here
and the way the season at hayden park
and turned him in he goes [ __ ] what
we're going to roll these guys and i was
like
mate where are they going to roll them
or we'll lose well either win by 40 or
lose and we lost like it was just the
way things were going
um and you look it was a really hard
time
for the organization like i remember
jamie being in tears in one meeting
with us leadership boys and like i went
from the captain i wasn't in a strat
leader
i was in the leadership group i wasn't
an attack group i was in the defense
group i was just a soldier on the ground
turning up to do the promos with the
boys and
to be fair that year i learned more
about myself than any other year and
was a pretty hard experience to go
through but it set me up
for like now as a coach understanding
what
different players go through and all the
rest of it so yeah it was pretty crazy
time like that it's crazy
and how hard is it when you're in a
position where you're a starter and then
straight away you're off doing the
promos and people are asking you why
aren't you playing you're getting this
constantly from people
yeah i don't know if social media was it
was a thing back then but
i'm just comments from everyone just
saying why aren't you playing what
what have you done sort of thing and
it's just hard for you to answer right
yeah 100 like i
i got a social media barrage after i got
a red card
from for southland against otago oh yeah
i had never experienced anything like it
um
so i sort of understand what people go
through and
oh my you just die deep into reading
things and hearing things and
i got into a pretty dark spot after that
but i think
all players have got to learn and i
learned it the hard way that
you know if you're gonna read stuff that
makes you feel good about your
self-worth
and makes you feel better about a person
well then you deserve to read the bad
stuff that
people write about you because what
you're doing is basing your self-worth
off people that
you don't know and respect um so the
guys that you
you respect and a lot of people say that
you know
it might not even be your coaches at the
time it might be
one of those coaches that's true to you
a couple of your mates and your parents
so
um i know that we live in this world
where we've got so accessible to this
negative information and all this kind
of stuff but
if you're a true professional you your
self-worth comes off
yourself and how you play and then a
particular small group around
around you that will give you honest
feedback about when you're good and bad
and the rest of it doesn't matter
so what sort of what sort of abuse were
you getting after the red card it must
have been a bad red card
ah just yeah mate just the same old [ __ ]
that everyone would always say they
become
pretty you know he's [ __ ] done he's
fair
he can't describe he's not good well you
know what i mean like i played along and
like
this might have only been a small amount
of people's opinions i'm sure
a lot of people in south and um
you know were appreciative of what i did
but it was a yeah no it was just
something that i went through and was a
bit tough at that time and i learned
from it and
you know i don't really buy into that
stuff anymore
did you get off social media after that
no i just i just
it's funny because you can go on there
like every player will do it you'll play
a game and then
maybe the homeless page will pop up and
there'll be 300 comments and if you've
had
a good game people go down and read them
yeah
like you'll flick through i'll be like
oh jimmy ma had a good game and you'll
be on the bus right here boy
um like you see so many players do it
so [ __ ] if you're prepared to go
down that line and look for good
comments about yourself you're gonna
feel bad
about the [ __ ] one so just don't do it
at all like don't even buy into it
because it's
it's people sitting at home's opinions
that evidently don't
don't [ __ ] matter a hundred percent i
could not agree more ways
another great piece of advice made
podcast
coming up trumps with all sorts of good
advice
so the year after you've been dropped
from being captain you're now hardly
playing
the following year is this when you let
go from highlanders and move up to the
chiefs
yeah bud so halfway through that year i
saw him with the chiefs told jamie
i was really upset with jamie how he
dealt with the whole thing
um because i actually played really well
that year we
first gave me one against the blues i
had a stormer and played like 80 minutes
and got a standing o when i come off the
field i was
i probably knew that was going to be my
last game at home for the hondas because
i knew i was going to leave
so i sort of rang my mom and dad and
said hey look come up this has probably
been my last game and
you know going to the chiefs was a
massive decision for me but it was based
on
wanting to be an all black and still
wanting to be in all black and i i went
up there with
the ability to scrum with ben affair and
being tamiya furna and be coached by
wayne smith tom commentary and dave
rinney um
and play with sam kane brodie retulic
and it was just such an amazing
opportunity and
um it was freaking scary for me because
like leaving the south island feels like
i'm in france but i went
up there and obviously i had an amazing
time with your brother up there and
learned a [ __ ] done about rugby and had
a [ __ ] ton of fun and it's another group
of mates
that i'll be friends with for the rest
of my life so it was an amazing
experience
yeah how did you find um dave rennie
really really good like he was one of
the best balance coaches that i've had
like
he delivered well um he didn't take any
[ __ ]
when you're at training he was a hard
bastard and
and you knew that you trained hard with
him and you knew he had a high work
ethic and
he demanded excellence off us and it
disappointed if he didn't get it
but he'd be the first guy to walk up the
bus and talk [ __ ] and talk about pubs
and
we love that he could clip out a rugby
and come talk to us about normal stuff
and
something that i you know i particularly
enjoyed um
working with renz and unfortunately it
didn't go as well as i would have liked
it the chiefs like
i tried and played some really good
games up there and
i was just in competition with a young
prop and poorly asimanu and
yeah i had some times up there where
um i got dropped and didn't you know i
missed out on playing
that's a good story actually your
brother is a goodbye guy
obviously the hollanders hollanders and
in the cargo would be the best game for
me to play in my life
and for whatever reason they changed the
team around a lot that week and i didn't
get picked
and i just couldn't believe it you know
like probably a bit of self-entitlement
everyone has self-entitlement
when you're playing playing rugby at a
higher level you think that you
owed things or i don't know i thought
that i was owed that game because it was
an invercargill when against my old team
and i couldn't believe it i come home
crying and
i think tojo got dropped that week too
and i was on a shitty
wednesday and i come i went into
training and did a walk bike and
i come back and he's sitting on the
couch with a big smile on his face
and he told me to go in the fridge and
open up the fridge and here put like 24
tuis and 24 spates in this fridge
and it was wednesday and with state of
origin
why we never drink the midwest [ __ ]
not a lot of the
not a lot of the time in my career in
new zealand that i drink midweek yeah
well beth come home from work tojo's
misses at like
5 30 six and we're hammered and we had
we've taken we've got a fake mustache
and we've stuck it to the tv and
tojo would have the remote and if you
could pause it on someone's face
and it looked like a proper mustache on
his face the other guy had to do two
bottles
so we did this the whole game a whole
day
and to be fair to say beth wasn't that
impressed she kicked us out
but yeah and one of many good days i had
with tojo out there to be fair
oh mate sounds like you guys had a hell
of a time and he obviously talked about
the mongrel mob
um story on his podcast the other day
run me through that one from your side
of things
well i was actually not too bad but then
i actually got a bit scared i was like
because tojo rang me up and was like
mate [ __ ] you gotta sort this [ __ ] out
man beth's freaking out she doesn't want
the mob to come around on my [ __ ] what
do you want me to do like
i just waved to him and uh
oh mate that was good stuff from the
mckenzie boys um
we had a lot of [ __ ] we had a lot of
games going on up there their stage
like my first year living with um
tojo we were obviously living with squid
liam squire and
man he's a cracking guy man i've
actually really really really enjoy
squiddy
um he was pretty young man and we picked
on him a fair bit
and we'd play this game when he come
home from training that first to talk to
squid he had to buy a 24
pack on friday nights so he would come
home from training and
to joke denny he'd just run to his room
and lock the door
and squid would walk in and i'd just
pretend to sleep on the couch and then
we'd try to avoid squid for like two or
three hours and he would lose it
oh we were always up to mischief it was
a lot of fun we played a lot of darts we
um
yeah we had a lot of good times any good
story surely you've got a few good dart
stories for the boys yeah so as
people know like tojo's a wonderful
person but he's the most competitive
bastard i've ever met like when he loses
he sucks
and uh whenever we play cards in the um
darts at nighttime i'd be winning he
would go to bed at like eight to think
um
and he wouldn't speak to me and then
whenever he's winning he'd be up roaring
at like 10 30 like
prancing around the house he used to
break me hey try growing up with him
[Laughter]
um we had a beer olympics at home one
day um
and we all paired up so see who could
drink the most beers and it was
like a partners are involved and the
mckenzie boys were um
the mckenzie boys were a team and they
were like paying buck one to be
fooded out for us because they couldn't
drink the buddy
they couldn't drink the skin off a wet
sheet and uh
matt toad so i got back from rugby and
tojo had been like sitting there playing
uh the horse racing cards game with
damien
and anyway we decided at the opening
ceremony national anthem before the beer
olympics and um damien mckenzie had
already gone into the toilet spewed and
jumped out the window
had no partner for the night so he did
it pretty tough
yeah he would have battled and talk me
through your um
i heard you went up to the cricket world
cup semi-final
one of the best nights of your life
wasn't it yeah well that sort of turned
out to be
one of the first times that i'd like
really got pissed
uh during the midwest um
[Music]
we got back from south africa we'd lost
or
drawn to the sharks over there there's
two red cards in each team like it was a
crazy game
anyway i got to the semi final of the
world cup
and i'm sitting there with the two
mckenzie boys and brad weather
fevers behind me in the box and he's
giving me beers and
as we know what happened that night was
probably one of the greatest sporting
events in new zealand history
yeah and look i'd had my phil and i
decided
i decided it was a too good opportunity
not to go close up with the beaver and
um so the mckenzie boys drove home to
hamilton
and webby was staying up there at a
girl's place and he swore he's going to
pick me up at like
6 30 in the morning getting me home for
training so off to danny derwin's i went
and um made about 4 30 in the morning it
hit me i'm like [ __ ] i've made a bad
decision here um
i jumped on the tax end i texted all the
way back to uh
all the way back into the hamilton and i
walk in and
tojo's like mate what are you doing
we've got training in half an hour so
dear look
i'll have a shower so
first meeting and i like me and tojo
used to sit up the back
and i didn't used to say too much and
renz was spraying the team about having
real poor preparation
and like i remember that week um as i've
told you many times the scrummaging was
a big thing for me so
we didn't have enough props to scrum
because we had injuries so
i got our ford's coach to organize
university props to come in and do our
scrum session
yeah um and then rinse is abusing the
whole team about like
having [ __ ] prep and made i've wiped up
the back like husky is a little
dog i was like ah [ __ ] reds i disagree
that's [ __ ]
and truth mojo just looks at me as like
shh
and i was like nah i can't hold myself
though
i've given it the rings about that like
i prep for that game really well
oh looking back because [ __ ] me wasn't a
good idea
oh good times but you obviously look
back at your chief's career
with very fond memories hugely like
the group of mates um we used to hang
out with was
me and brother uh andrew harrell legend
um sammy kane
aaron cruden brodie ritalic the mckenzie
boys
quinton mcdonald we all lived in the
same little area and um
and webby and we like we had so much fun
we worked hard we trained hard
and i learned the most about rugby out
there i
i hung off every word that wayne smith
said um i love getting coached by rims
wren's
and now that i'm coaching myself i look
back and just realize how much i did
learn up there and
yeah it was excellent so how did the
next part of your career
happen was it a hard decision to leave
new zealand and give up on your all
black dream i guess
well i didn't really have an option
denny um
renz was really good to me sort of said
look we're not probably going to resign
you for next year
um we're going to put you into the draft
and that we might pick you up on a first
year contract so
yeah like is the first time my life
since i've been 18 that i i never had a
contract and it was really really scary
long story short i went home to the farm
and i
sort of and i was getting over just
trying to be an all black again and
putting so much pressure on myself and i
got a call
to go to play for the bar bars and
twickenham
against argentina so um i
heard a no contract hitting over there
and there was talk of like a club
london welsh or some [ __ ] club wanted me
to
play the rest of scene for them so when
i i pulled my bags to the airport with
mum and dad and they're like
well i don't know when i'll be home
probably for christmas or maybe after i
don't know
um i went and played bar bars and you
get your 5 000
cash uh in your wee envelope and um
and after the barbers i was like i might
as well go down to montpellier and see
my best mate tom donnelly so
i flew down there and um
i got on the bus there were so many good
boys there a lot of aussies that are now
great mates with ben marwen and i've got
pat celias jesse mogg nick white
um corey flynn was up in toulouse so
here i am there on
on the piss for the week like leading
these boys astray
and i get to the after match watching
montpellier play and jake white come up
to me is like
oh jamie what are you doing um i was
like
mate i'm on holiday he's like oh we're
back for super and i was like no
no i've got no contract but um things
sort of didn't really work out
and he's like oh [ __ ] um would you be
interested in playing here
and i was like of course i would um
because i haven't got a spot for you now
but if there's an injury i'll give
you a buzz i said well actually i'm
going to in stan ball i'm going i want
to go down to anzac cove and
i'll do a bit of traveling before i
possibly go home at christmas so i'll
stay here before
i go on holiday and then i'll come back
so i trained all the way up to marseille
and this is not a word of a lie
i'm walking down the air bridge to get
on the plane and my phone went off and
it was jake white and cj bundle and
ruptured his bicep tendon
um at training wow so
i didn't speak any french um got my
all my bags off the airplane i don't
even know how i got my bags back i don't
know how i got back from marseille down
to montpellier i don't know any of the
train ones
um got back on wednesday signed
contracts for
six months for montpellier none of the
boys knew either so
none of the guys that i've been pissing
up for two weeks know
and i was kept on telling them the story
about um
michael jordan when he got dropped from
his high school team he used to train on
the corporate side and
just just do shots so i said i'm just
going to turn up to training and just
like
just start running on the side of the
field and hopefully get picked up
and then mate when i run out to training
on thursday honestly the whole squad
lost it they were losing it
true um that was the start of my journey
overseas bud like
i did a six-month medical joker in
montpellier which was a hell of a time
um then scott wiseman the current
australian coach
he was coaching there he knew a bloke in
um america and he said you want to go
play in america so i went to ohio
had an amazing time there i signed a
contract on a photocopier i showed it to
ports he said you
you'll be the stupidest bloke i know if
you sign that and i said well you
haven't got me anything
um wait what else am i going to sign
nothing and he was laughing so
had an amazing experience here and then
off the back end of that
um i was just finished the final um
in the american comp my mom my dad and
my uncle were doing a trip
through like um nashville memphis new
orleans and the phone rang
it was poe um carl heyman and simon
mannix i had an injury
to a prop and i flew over there on an
injury cover really fit
and um i played the second game and then
i ended up playing every game for the
club for the next four years
crazy
unbelievable scenes it is absolutely
nuts
yeah so yeah every little journey
to be fair the last little bit of my
life hasn't been about my rugby it's
been about how
people have known and also taking like
bizarre little opportunities that other
people probably wouldn't
um the one to go to america was massive
because it's
like here i am in america in a probably
the most exciting competition in the
world which is going to blow up and
yeah i feel pretty privileged and pretty
proud that i had the balls to like
go over there at a time where i could
have
easily stayed in france or done
something a lot more mainstream and
mate again i met a massive bunch of boys
that were like absolute lads
so your career has been pretty crazy how
you've like the first half of your
career you were purely southland
highlanders you were the local legend
and in the second half of your career
you've been everywhere you've met so
many different people
and you're a real big people person too
aren't you like you connect well with
lots of different people from around the
world so um how you've done your career
is pretty cool
yeah and i've always said i've learned
my lessons in life from probably
the hardest situations like getting
dropped from the hondas
getting let go by the chiefs not making
the all blacks again
having my best mate flicked me from
southland
what it taught me was that like no
matter what you're doing like rugby's
rugby
um but like i try to treat everybody the
way i want to be treated myself and like
i love having a better crack i'm like
really professional my job and
when i'm at training i'm really serious
but apart from that like
like life like yeah just treat other
people i want to be treated and i really
i get up and live that every day um and
try to like
every time i leave a conversation i want
someone to feel better about themselves
or
feel on a buzz and um i really
yeah i've learned that and i love i love
that that's the way i am with people so
yeah it's been massive
you are a good kid anyway as always
we've gone to our instagram for some
questions and
like you said you've met so many people
and a lot of them seem like quite
customers we got plenty of questions
in first question
phil burley all these lads tell him he
still owes me 200 pounds for that jacket
he gave to a homeless person
man so i travel this is a land story
i travel from france up to wales to
watch hard's play his
second or third test for scotland and i
convinced beryls to come down
from he had been playing for ember the
night before so
he turned up in wales in the morning
like in full intricate
and he was like [ __ ] whopper i need to
go buy so we went and bought him some
clothes he bought a nice shirt and
t-shirt and then
he bought this real nice jacket like it
was 220 pound this nice green long
jacket
so we're on the piss that night at tiger
tiger with the scottish team
and um mate this story is good
phil burley abused gareth anskim's
sister and she threw a drink in him
like i don't know what happened it just
all kicked off and barrels is wet and
hearts is like over it so
those two boys stand up and leave and
they walk back to their hotel
so i go to the coat room grabble out
coats and as i get to the
hotel room i'm not allowed in so i bring
hearts and barrels i'm like
[ __ ] let me in like i've got all the
coats and they're like no you can't come
up the security is like real anal
and then i got real shitty and i said to
pearl's man if you don't let me in i'm
giving your jacket away to the first
homeless bike i met
and then he won't so i put him on
facetime and i walked up to this
homeless guy on this bench and gave him
the jacket
and then i went back to the hotel oh man
we were hammered
oh that's a good one that's
ruthless love that okay do you get free
whoppers
no oh no never but um i remember we got
our skin folds done for the hondas and
one of my first rangers had the walker
on the side of it
scratcher obviously one of the great
lads will find legend
he consistently struggled with his
controls throughout his career
he had a good day so we went through
burger king and
i pulled up to the window and and there
sometimes there are a couple of
sandwiches short of a picnic obviously
it's
this lady looked out the window and she
was like
um is that all and i said oh yeah i'm
sorry i get free um
burger king um i'm sponsored like look
at my truck and she leaned out and said
say no it's the walker and she goes oh
[ __ ] so the manager came out and
he looked like he'd lick more windows
than the first person
and um he was like have you got your
card your gold card and i said mate it's
at home i'm so sorry bro like
normally i just get free free burger
king and he's like i'll tell you what i
can do
um i'll give you a 75
off is that okay and i'm like yeah
that'll do
we had this massive order
so i never got any free but i did talk
myself into a pretty good order
you've got a good discount oh okay
next one what's the niggliest thing
you've ever done on the field
there'll be a few of these you're a grub
i wasn't
i do know what i think
the decline of that southland team
because we're so good and then we went
real
[ __ ] that's when i become a bit of a
grub because i was getting so
[ __ ] frustrated me and cozy used to
love having a go
i remember one game down in rugby park
he
elbowed me in the head in this clean out
and then
i've seen red and i come into the next
clean out and as i rained out i upper
cutted him and
i actually upper cutted him and he had
no mouth guard on and i knocked out his
front tooth
and he slipped my hand like four
centimeters here
and he went right off and then he just
got up and started punching that
saunders in the face repeatedly and it
was like
what's cracking up and then we get to
the scrum
and i had my hand was bleeding so bad i
had in my back pot like sure
and the ref's like i'm going to sit in
venues too for fighting and cause he's
like
mate it wasn't even saunders there's
whopper that
fat he's a piece of [ __ ] he was going
right off
um and i was hiding my hand because my
hand was just full of blood
um but he found his tooth on the field
after the game but
russia was really interesting like
obviously we're all great major thrushy
he always said that me and cozy would
get along so well but we just used to
get onto the field and fight each other
and actually now they were a little bit
older we sent each other a few messages
and i've
seen him a few times he's the top man
but it's funny when you're
young you just think that some guy you
just want to attack him and he wants to
attack you and that's what happens
both absolute niggle goats you too
but lads off the field absolute lads off
the field niggly on it
love that okay next question crooks yarn
from your shield celebrations
don't hold back whops on day four after
the
we got knocked down the semi-final a lot
of them
we were pissing up at our place and they
were the fire was going and
you know the poker for the fire it
looked like the shape of the ramford
steel and these boys were hammered so
like
nine of them are lined up pants down
bent over the couch
and got branded themselves on the ass
and it turned out to be the worst
decision that any of them blokes were
made late
i think four of them ended up infected
in hospital
um the expanded team photo they couldn't
sit on the chairs they're
they're in agony oh you didn't be on
boys relating their judge no they tried
to do me and i
i run away there's no way they've done
that oh that's good stuff
okay what were you thinking during the
yes please moment
oh it's pretty like it doesn't look like
it but i did quite a lot to drink
i just thought it was funny um
but i look back at their video christ
it's embarrassing like
i look like i'm about 19 years old
hearts looks like a [ __ ]
same spree wants to knock us out um
we just shouldn't have been on tv it's
been embarrassing
one of the great moments of tv no doubt
okay
okay hottest person to scrum against oh
[ __ ]
um most people would agree that pro
rugby there's not really an easy day
everybody's hard um
obviously when i was young carl heyman
was really really good he used to tickle
me up for training
all the time when i went to francais
that was where
i tested the middle um there's a guy
slovani from
claremont and a massive like huge
big georgian dude who'd been like in the
top 14 for 40
like 16 seasons and i remember playing
them just thinking
holy [ __ ] like i'm just a boy
that was massive over there yet there's
some lonely lonely days in france
but when i first got to montpellier they
had
four international tie heads one was
nicolas muss
who would be 103 kilo and he played 80
or 90 tests for france and
looking at him i was just like hey i'm
gonna murder the folks
he spat me up sideways upwards downwards
backwards
like i don't even know where he was half
the time
um but i think it was those competitions
at montpellier that made me a way better
scrummager
but it certainly um was a painful
process to go through to be fair
no doubt okay next one i heard you're
the only prop to do a snow beaver
um one of the tiger lads or coach so
what is a snow beaver by the way so
that's great stuff jimmy i'll i'll fill
you in because
a snow beaver's this little animal that
lives in the mountains and
uh he forages for food on the ground but
the only time he sticks his head out of
his hole
is when he's looking for like a female
snow beaver to breed with
so last year for the otaku team i told
all the loose fords that if i see any
snow beavers for the year that
i'd kicked them off the tent so if they
stuck their head
off the scrum that was counted as a snow
beaver
and to be fair we had we had no loose
woods leave the scrum early so
it obviously worked mate you're a great
coach okay next question
any tips for a young prop um
yeah be patient um be patient but at the
same time work hard
so always be fit um
every props different so like some props
don't put on weight easy
some bops hold like whatever your little
regime is you've got to be really good
at
so stay fit
stay big and stay strong and just be
patient with your technique and
make sure you've got good people
coaching you and
you know don't don't get over anxious if
it's not working straight away just
hang in there and um take a few hidings
and learn from them and um
and you'll be far better off wait no
wonder you're a coach
gee whiz that's powerful
you're in the you're in the right career
after footy
okay only two more questions plans after
footy
i'm guessing it's coaching but
yeah look i yeah i i
did uh took me 12 years
uh to finish to complete my degree
through mass uni
um bachelor of sports science majoring
in like
coaching and management so i always had
a passion for coaching
um and it's definitely a pathway i want
to go down but
also as you know jimmy comes with
in its purest form it's one of the
coolest things you can do like coaching
otago tasman getting the lads better
being involved in a group um i'm just
not too sure
after being away for eight or nine years
or eight seven years
if you want to coach you've got to be
prepared to move your family and do the
whole rugby thing all over again
um so there's something that's playing
on my mind but
it's definitely something i think that i
could be good at
um and have a real passion for
it's just how does that fit into life
then
part of me also what is excited about
trying sonic awesome life and
i think if you applied the same things
you learned from rugby like we've talked
about
work ethic and the many things in rugby
you learn
into another job i think we would all be
successful as well so
part of me in the back of my mind wants
another challenge at some stage but
i'm at this stage on an opportunity to
coach full-time
around the world and back in new zealand
and um and i think i'll pursue that for
another couple years
any ideas what that other challenge
would be any anything else that stands
out to as an interest for you
um i've been thinking a little bit about
real estate
um i grew up on the farm was a big farm
bullying
probably never suited to go back to the
farm with my personality like being such
a people's person
we sold the family farm a couple years
ago
maybe something in that rural sector
like i actually wouldn't mind
getting into radio unlike royal radio or
sports radio
um or there'll be something there um
i definitely have narrowed down the
stuff that i think i want to be
or could be good at and that i would
enjoy your stomach around those lines
you'll dominate anything you choose no
doubt
too gifted okay last question
what is the best piece of advice you've
received in your career
and i've said a few guys have come up
with the best ones lately but
after what i've heard from this podcast
and you've sprinkled little bits
throughout this episode
i feel like this could potentially be
the greatest piece of advice ever i'm
looking forward to it
i don't know um jeez i've probably
already said them all yeah well you have
said a lot
i think treating other people the way
you want to be treated yourself as big
um you know where you put your energy
so there's no point putting your energy
into
people and places that don't give you
the right energy back
um and you'll learn that in life like
you're going to have good friends and
blah blah so make sure your energy is
always
um going to the people that mean the
most to you and give you the most fun
back
um which really comes back to like
as i said just being myself
always being myself which can and you
know
um jimmy as a coach and sometimes it's
actually
sometimes really hard to be yourself
when you're put under pressure
and do certain things in life but i
think one thing i always want to do is
is be myself because i think people can
tell straight away when you're not and
i've had coaches that
have become under pressure and become
not themselves and as a player you just
see it and smell it straight away
so no matter what the situation no
matter what's going on just
stick to what i know and stick to being
myself and stick to
treating people well
powerful that's what i love about
hosting a podcast is you get to learn
so much from the most intelligent
players
from all around the world who have seen
a little bit of everything and mate what
a career
what an absolute career you've had it's
still gone danny i know
one more year and i'll call it quits i
think if i play next year i might
get over 350 programs i think i might be
one or two sure
what would stop you from still going if
you're feeling good
no if i was feeling good physically i
would keep going um
but for everybody out there who plays
footy you know it's a serious commitment
to get your body ready and to keep it
right
it's a massive commitment yeah um the
running the
fitness you're either all in you can't
be half half
um yeah so next year i'm going to give
it one more crack
and then hopefully the 45 guy can throw
me a massive party in austin somewhere
and i'll invite everyone
from around the world
private jet you're dating over for a
weekend oh go on
right how good honestly it's been an
absolute pleasure having you on the
podcast horse
looking forward to seeing you in action
this year for otago if not on the field
but at least
in the coaching box uh no doubt you'll
do great things with them and then of
course
back to austin where um you're doing
amazing things by the sounds of it over
there so
mate really appreciate you coming on the
podcast you're an absolute lad and
um giving up your time and iso thank you
very much jenny and
um all the best for your season and
tasman uh i don't think we're gonna play
these eh
no not from memory not all the best bud
and hopefully um
i need to get up and see tojo i haven't
seen him for a few years yeah come
on come do a trip to mapu november he'll
fill the fridge for you
hopefully cheers
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you